FRONT.
PUCK COMES FREE T CARLSSON AND S
ON THE SAMEY YOU HAVE A
ONE-NOTHING LEAD.
>> FIRST POWER PLAY
WON ATHANASIOU TOOK THE DRAW,
AND THEN THE IT IS.'S IMPORTANTY
AGAIN.
RIGHT OFF THE FACE-OFF, THIS
TIME
HEAD.
MATT ROY COUGHS UP THE P
HERTL FROM THE MAKEINGA CHANGE.O
ACTUALLY DEVELOP THEM INTO NHLH.
STICK ON PUCK BY ONTARIO, AND T,
AND LANGUAGE EVERYONE USES, YOU
TRY TO KEEP ROLLS BACK TO THE KS
END.
KOPITAR IS ONHLEN HANDLES.
SPENCE UP ON THE RUSH,H, ICE, BG
REBOUND, TRIED TO PUT IT BACK ON
NET.
THE GO BACK.
BONINO GOAL LINE, OUT WIDE IT TK
NOT BEING SHOT BALCERS.
POKE THE ZONE,
NOW ITS NUMBERS ANDERSON, FOURT,
MATT ROY, SEVENTH ROUND.P SHN WR
MOORE.
FOR THE PUCK AGENTS THE NEAR
THREE ON THREE, NO PROBLEM AT
ALL.
FOUR MINUTES REMAINING IN